it's another red mama hour again give it
up for the mamas of the world
[Applause]
i don't know about y'all but i have been
dreaming of some mommy time in the sun
these days especially as things slowly
start to open up
i've learned the zoom as they say um yep
they wrote it in there okay i know it's
just zoom they're making me sound old
it's fine i'm with it look the zoom
i've mastered the face time um i can
check in with my kiddos and love them
from afar for a couple of days we all
need it
i'm thinking beach please yes
please please so here to tell us about
some of the best
mommy getaways let's welcome back the
travel mama herself emily kaufman
everybody
everybody it's good to be back
so put together like how i envision
myself looking when i leave my house but
it doesn't happen
um so what's your first recommendation
for moms who want a summer escape
moms are so busy taking care of
everybody else that they don't really
take care of themselves and great
it's a wonderful way to go away and get
some terrific r and r
with the cove atlantis on paradise
island in the bahamas
this is a wonderful resort spread out
where there's luxurious white sand
beaches cabanas that face both the pool
and the beach celebrity inspired
award-winning restaurants an adults-only
pool
and it's a great place to go so mom can
let somebody
else take care of her for a change i
love that i'm going to be so sad this
whole episode just closing my eyes
wishing i was there
i also want to mention that the cove is
making it very easy for people when they
travel
because the bahamas requires a health
visa
you have to upload a negative covent
test before you go and
at the cove they give free testing for
the people who are staying on property
and they also give you a free test
because the cdc requires that before you
board a flight to go back home
so you've got everything right there
under one roof yeah that's great
actually um well good news emily's not
just telling us about
ideal vacations she's helping us give
some away so anyone in the house see
it's
interested in an escape to the bahamas
does anyone
is any everyone lit up okay all right
let's get our light show
shuffle underway when i say go the
lights will flash on
random audience members until they land
on someone whoever it stops on is
getting the ultimate vacation
which includes a seven day romantic
getaway to the cove at atlantis in the
bahamas
you'll experience luxurious
accommodations and daily breakfast for
two
let's get to this y'all joe ready go
who will it be who will it be
who will it be all right where's it at
[Applause]
all right so wait what's what's your
name
my name's elena well now you're getting
seven days of fun
so you will enjoy my gosh oh my gosh
thank you so much
absolutely i love that accent as well
all right so what's next
you know there are many people who want
to have a tropical exotic vacation but
they're not quite ready to leave the
country
and hawaii's a tourist place to visit
for that
now the grand hyatt resort and spa on
the island of kauai
is one of my favorite pool areas ever
you could see yourself floating in a
saltwater lagoon with
an adult beverage or enjoying pacific
hawaiian
food at tide pools restaurant and kauai
has so many great ways to be in the
great outdoors
and hawaii has a safe travels protocol
in place
meaning you have to upload a negative
covid test 72 hours before you go
you receive a qr code that's sort of
your admission
into your airline your hotel your
different things and i flew on hawaiian
airlines
which made this completely seamless and
easy plus
you feel their aloha spirit the minute
you get on the plane
so you know you're on a vacation yes you
get laid right when you get there it's
awesome
um that's right i had to do it um so in
any that's right i'm still 15.
would any of you want to get away to
hawaii anybody probably no one
no one yep okay okay well this is for us
i'm the band
yes this is for a six night luxury
getaway to the grand hyatt kauai resort
and spa
in hawaii you'll enjoy spectacular ocean
views great restaurants and a
championship golf course
plus airfare is courtesy of hawaiian
airlines hawaii's largest
and longest serving airline let's give
another trip away i'm just saying i've
been to this hotel you're gonna have a
good time
joe hit it
[Applause]
where's it going where's it going
where's it going who should it be who
shall it be
who is it
oh oh i'm so excited because you're so
excited so what's your name
[Applause]
my name is amber john oh well amber have
you ever been to hawaii or kawaii
oh you're gonna love it it's so much fun
i've actually stayed where you're
staying and it's so
beautiful you're going to love it i
suggest the atv tours too they're very
cool and it's like where they did
jurassic park
you can like drive through it there's
like a rope swing you feel like indiana
jones it's very magical
anyway i hope you have so much fun thank
you so much
absolutely oh i love when they get that
excited um well thank you so much emily
we love having you here
you happy mother's day to you happy
mother's day yes want more fun stuff
i thought so check out these videos
floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure